Platinum Dunes reading also the movie
lets us know upfront we're gonna have to
keep up with days and/or dates and times
and just all that so the concept is if
you make a sound the creatures
immediately hear you and they attack and
kill you knowing this how did it ever
get to the point where anyone was ever
able to put these signs up are you
telling me these people didn't make any
noises while doing this sure let your
kid run unsupervised through this
abandoned grocery store with all this
shit on the floor I'm sure he's not
clumsy enough to make any noise but in
frolic so hard for kids to just be kids
these days since they're getting eaten
please notice the hearing aid no
seriously please notice it man no one is
very good at looting in this town even
when there were enough people to loot
the shit out of it there appears to be a
lot of packages of candy and nuts
available and there are still plenty of
drugs behind the pharmacy counter I
assume that's racist
oh we F we go we totally trust our son
not to pick that rocket back up and do
what kids normally do which is to
totally ignore their parents and take
the rocket anyway first off the New York
Post's front page would be more like
president sounds off turn your sound off
or Simon Says no one dude disturb the
sound of silence or sound found to
compound the frowns second off this
newspaper basically says that the
invasion was so advanced that they found
out the problem was sound much too late
to do anything about it yet the New York
Post was still putting out newspapers as
if fully staffed it's like they found
out the problem was sound and then the
creatures ate the entire headquarters of
the New York Post on the same day yeah
Reagan should know better than to give
this kid a toy rocket and leave him
behind with those tempting batteries
Within Reach
but our Evelyn and lean seriously not
worried about where their two kids are
they walked out of the store 15 seconds
ago and despite the world of danger
they're in nobody's bothered to check if
the kids are still with them this is the
absolute worst way to walk back home
with your family in a world where the
sound sensitive creatures are lurking
everywhere you know if the kid who's
most likely to cause trouble bringing up
the rear of the single-file line out of
sight of the parents it's a wonder he
didn't get killed sooner also I'm
wondering why everybody had to go on
this trip anyway if the parents were
just gonna let one of their kids run
around the store without keeping an eye
on him what difference would it have
made if Reagan babysat this kid at home
[Music]
what exactly is the noise threshold here
they're clearly making some noise when
they're walking around there are popping
leaves everywhere and I know they Yatta
Yatta add some sand in but how could
they possibly have gathered that much
fucking sand to pull everywhere and how
did they figure out how much noise they
could make did they originally have like
a family of ten and then lost a few when
testing out theories
kids now I've got to do King math to
figure out how many days it's been since
Bo died and that the Los Angeles Times
would like everyone to know they can
hear you also in this newspaper you can
get the racing results because a very
early racing was going on went out
anyone at the track getting eaten during
this time also I'm sure everything is
being powered by a generator here what
with The Electric Company probably not
in business anymore but don't generators
make noise even if you found a
relatively quiet one wouldn't it produce
more decibels than a toy rocket also
also just think about how many people
have died going outside to pick up a
paper that was going to let them know
how to survive and of course Evelyn's
pregnant because movie how irresponsible
of these fucking people how do they even
have quiet sex like men are capable of
having sex without sobbing loud or I
mean so here also Evelyn's baby bunk
brings up even more questions like how
do you keep a baby quiet even if you put
the baby in a soundproof room until you
can communicate with it and teach it
sign language you still have the problem
of kids being kids especially in an age
when they don't understand the gravity
of the situation sure a kid would grow
up learning sign language rather than
speaking but then they'd have to learn
how to move without making no noise and
stifle all their crying and you still
have the problem you have with rocket
man earlier the kid could never go
outside of that soundproof room for
years totally get protecting yourself
but those kids are going to make an
awful lot of noise when they pass out
and crash to the floor from all the glue
fumes so do the creatures not have the
ability to smell either because that
fire is definitely not a great idea if
they do the movie never says one way or
another but surely hearing isn't their
only sense fake floor fish problem with
a movie that shows us a room this well
lit is that you wonder why they ever
needed a fucking Lantern close by this
house is filled with electric lights all
over the place so this Lantern is merely
serving its purpose as an unnecessary
troublemaker nearly impossible raccoons
show up to be jump scurrying dicks just
when Lee starts looking for creatures
outside also who cares if this noise was
a raccoon and not a creature wouldn't
the creature come running after this
furry dumbass as soon as he screeched
outside kids how did he even acquire all
this equipment
how many electronic stores could be
within walking distance and some of the
stuff looks like you'd have to special
order it Neil shadowing also I can see
why this wooden staircase would need
nails because there are places where
nails are necessary but why the fuck is
there a nail right in the middle of this
step nowhere near anything that fastens
the step to anything else on the
staircase what exactly was this nail
nailing
diddly test this theory out himself one
day I mean it makes sense that the
waterfall would cover up the noise but
why take a chance it should be noted
that this girl who is hearing-impaired
is looking straight ahead disregarding
all those noisy crunchy leaves remember
these kids are walking on their tippy
toes around the house trying to make
sure they don't make any noise
but sure this girl can walk over leaves
and not good kill what happened I would
hope not
it's been a whole 319 400 and math
conveniently everyone is having their
own little remember bone moment as Lea
and Marcus are having their conversation
it was no one's fault
except that it was totally Reagan's
fault I guess this movie thought you
were bored so this random old guy will
now scream about his dead wife so that
we can see the creature do some
murdering again kind of amazing it
happened on the very day Lea took his
son out in the woods for the first time
oh wow Evelyn's water broke at a super
inconvenient time that's surprising said
no one do you so hard moving also tennis
we're about to see one of these things
walking around the house and these
creatures have acute hearing but they
can't hear a breaker switch being
flipped also if these creatures have
such acute hearing that they know
exactly where a noise came from why
isn't this thing already down here
searching for its dinner also also this
monster was very quiet when it entered
the house does it use the front door
instead of smashing through a window
every single time these creatures
attacked they were in full-on cue mode
so it's kind of crazy that this creature
was so polite even if it didn't bother a
knock first
Jesus how long are these assholes
investigate sounds if their prey made a
sound three minutes ago how do they hope
to find it if it's not making noise
anymore god dammit I knew those aliens
from science would somehow figure into
this farmhouse horror movie let this
asshole up here Evelyn ran up the stairs
while the creature was thrashing about
in the basement so what did it here cool
she gave birth during the fireworks that
would cover up all the yelling and
screaming for sure but how did she cut
her own umbilical cord did she manage to
take some scissors with her while she
was running for her life also Evelyn's
water broke like ten minutes ago she
went through the quickest labor birth
and getting the baby to sleep in the
history of childbirth all because the
movie wants her to live movies look guys
I'm not gonna run silently out in the
open when there are blind murder demons
lurking about so instead I'll run much
louder through the core
can't be seen by those same murder
demons who are blind and have awesome
hearing I guess it's like steering into
the skid when you're driving on ice yeah
you didn't think about that did ya I
mean the economic burden of having a
third child of course you've been
planning for a baby for nine months and
couldn't figure out a proper door for
your height a baby room I know you can't
make a noise so stuff like hammering is
out of the question unless you've got a
bunch of fireworks to shoot off one day
yeah well this baby in a box wearing an
oxygen mask thing is definitely going to
work for this movie but realize this
would need to happen almost every day
what let's give a conservative estimate
of one and four chance that the creature
shows up any time the baby makes noise
that means a full quarter of your ear is
hiding out down here with only a
mattress between you and a bloodthirsty
creature also this baby's going to have
some traumatic childhood memories to get
over hopefully there are some therapists
left when he's older okay so we're being
total dicks to this movie for no good
reason it must be said that the use of
sound and the lack thereof is amazing
also any movie that is so tense that it
makes assholes feel the need to be quiet
in a theater is doing something right
so we're going to remove five cents sure
this ear thing is convenient as but at
least it's not water that ends up being
the Saviour Stillson for the convenience
you're saying I can't hear us okay so
now the movie is probably cheating on
the amount of sound these creatures can
hear from any random spot in the woods
they can apparently hear a picture frame
crash in a basement but they couldn't
hear any of the noise down here because
yeah yes sound proved it but you've got
a mattress over the opening I agree
mattresses could provide some sound
proofing but we're talking about
creatures with hearing ability that has
1053 percent better than humans
congratulations that jump-scare just
cost you your life oh wait it didn't
damn half good of these creatures
hearing again sure this water shows up
right as Lee starts walking away and
that's the movie's explanation for him
not seeing it but how does it not hear
it the thing Evelynn doesn't snore or
make any other bodily noises when she
sleeps
speaking of which we could have a whole
discussion on how this family trained
themselves not to make any body noises
while asleep
here's some bolt right here earlier in
this movie Lee and Marcus were yelling
like a bunch of assholes behind a
waterfall because it was safe but now
that the creature is directly next to
loud water he can hear she's half a mile
away
little known fact this movie was
originally about killer corn and they
decided to leave one with the scenes in
WoW earlier even that door fell into the
silo I thought that was terrible luck
for Marcus as he almost got smashed by
it but now I realize it was great luck
because it's like the headboard and
Titanic that saves well at least Rose I
would have removed all the sins if he
had pulled out some other person from
the core like this is the perfect time
for a Matt Damon cameo sure it would
have ruined all the suspense but Matt
David how the hell did this monster jump
into the silo with only one opening into
it that they were looking at without
being seen and especially heard at least
by Marcus you think this dick had
climbed up a silo without making some
noise does it no it's in the movie
called a quiet place if they were
sinking before getting on top of the
broken silo door why are they not
sinking now like they would sing right
but the door would stay above the corner
hey he left a nice human size hole to
walk out of it sure was nice of him wait
hasn't this movie broken its own rules
these creatures are blind with super
hearing but what exactly did Lee do here
that attracted the attention of this
thing
and why was it sitting on the top of the
shit anyway alien creature I got these
big teeth and claws but I'd rather just
sneak up on you when the movie needs
suspense
oh no the t-rex found lexan Tim dr.
grant quick distracted with a road flare
[Music]
great moment at all but I guess this
creature has a profound sense of drama
to allow it to happen right after it
heard a noise that usually causes an
instant murder/death/kill man how upset
is she gonna be when she realizes later
if she just left her earpiece setting
the way it was she could have saved her
father
I guess he's making a sacrifice and
that's what's important here but I'm
kind of surprised he didn't want to at
least try to hit the monster with his
axe but you know sometimes when you're
playing Dark Souls he just realized it's
impossible and give up
Oh the creatures gone is it all over man
it's great when someone can sacrifice
themselves and all the creatures just
leave wait that's not what happened then
why are they risking all this emotion
outside where there are still creatures
lurking about look before I didn't say
anything about Evelyn not doing anything
about this nail because she was giving
birth at the time and I hear that's a
high stress event also she was being
chased by murder aliens which is a close
second to childbirth but now she's been
safe in the house for a whole day and at
the very least put a krylon cap over
that thing so everyone knows where it is
and can avoid it
Regan does not know about the nail but
as usual none of her parents love her
enough to tell her that what exactly
brought this thing here it make a sound
yes these guys are sentient and can
remember where they heard noises before
and at least can make out that humans
live around here but now this creature
is just being a dick there's no reason
for it to be here other than the movie
needed a revelation about them at the
end so it's not about to have a Keyser
sze moment and save the day is she yep
yes she is kinda hard to believe that
the military or anybody who ever tried
to shoot one of these things never found
this easily detectable weak spot to kill
them you might be thinking well they
need the hearing aids feedback to weaken
them before they expose the weak spot
and I'm telling you this is not what the
movie showed us earlier before Reagan
started making noise ah you know what
that means the security cameras are
coming back online just in time for
everyone to realize that there are more
creatures coming and everyone can get in
the classic hearing aid distraction any
Oakley position
I do love this ending we got some
badasses in here remove a sin movie 30
inches of thigh slapping blood pumping
nuclear brain damage
[Music]
where are they I will find him I promise
I will never die
[Music]
dear Lord baby Jesus or as our brothers
to the South call you hey Zeus we thank
you so much for this bountiful harvest
of Domino's KFC and it always delicious
Taco Bell I immediately regret this
decision